[Music]
well that is taps
and it is some of the most heartfelt
memorial day tributes that contain no
words just those 24 notes taps the
unmistakable bugle call played at
military funerals and this memorial day
weekend cbs news on the road
correspondent steve hartman is back with
something he's very passionate about
it's called taps across america steve
joins us live from catskill new york to
talk about what's becoming a tradition
for you and for viewers good morning
steve so good to see you this morning
good morning sherry thanks for having me
you bet so for people who may not know
or heard of taps across america
tell us a little about it and what are
you asking people to do this year
we're asking buglers and trumpet players
really any kind of musician
to play taps
at three o'clock local time
and they don't have to go far just out
on the front porch or the backyard patio
we just want as many people as possible
commemorating the holiday
with taps
why is it important that we pause at 3
p.m local time to play taps what is it
about that time
well three o'clock is the national
moment of remembrance
and i think it's important that we pause
and um i'm asking people to play taps
because i kind of felt like
the purpose of the holiday had gotten
lost to some extent there were picnics
and
hamburgers and hot dogs and water
balloon fights but really the whole
reason we celebrate is to honor our
fallen and i thought this would be the
perfect way to put out the call
literally to pause for just these 24
notes and remember why we have memorial
day in the first place
so you're getting your responses have
been tremendous this is the third year
tens of thousands of people have
participated
all over the country with all kinds of
different instruments what is your
ultimate goal for taps across america
ultimately if this tradition continues
as i dearly hope it does
i like that i would like that no matter
where you live in america from the
biggest cities to the
the furthest out country roads that you
hear taps that it's lofting over every
neighborhood and every street in america
that's my ultimate goal and judging by
the response we've gotten so far and it
builds every year i think we're going to
get there
and you don't have to be a professional
musician right you're just asking
everybody you've even had people learn
how to play an instrument just so they
could participate
we've had lots of people do that and
those are the most emotional videos for
me when people send in their videos
because
you know yeah they're not perfect but i
just think of the hours they spend it's
not that easy to learn but people have
spent hours and they try to play it as
best they can because it means that much
to them and and that's that's what
really gets to me more than anything
okay
we'll have the information of where
people can submit their videos so that
they can participate and i'm sure you'll
pick the best ones and as many as you
can and play them so that people can see
themselves so thank you so much taps
across america we wish you the best
again and i expect that you're going to
get a resounding response like you have
for the last couple of years steve so
thanks so much and we always enjoy
everything you do so and good memorial
day weekend to you
thank you thank you very much for having
me i appreciate it you bet nice to talk
to you as always